[MUSIC PLAYING]
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Hi, and
welcome to the ninth episode
of the Google Cloud
Platform Podcast.
I am Francesc Campoy.
And I'm here with my
co-host Mark Mandel.
Hey, Mark.
MARK MANDEL: Hey, Francesc.
How you doing today?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Pretty good.
Happy new year.
MARK MANDEL: Happy
new year to you, too.
Good start of the year.
Brand new podcast episode.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
Finally, finally.
Took a couple weeks extra,
but I'm finally back
to the United States.
And I'm actually very
excited about this episode.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, it's
going to be a good one.
I'm pretty happy about it.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
Before we even talk about what
the main content's going to be,
let's start with a
cool thing of the week.
MARK MANDEL: Cool thing
of the week I like a lot,
I'm definitely a big
fan of the command line.
Especially being a
Linux user as well.
And I really like
the blog post we're
seeing today of the top five
power features of the Google
Cloud CLI.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: There's
some tricks in here
that I didn't know
about, that I thought
were particularly impressive.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
Especially if you are
a command line person.
And especially if you know how
to use [INAUDIBLE] and sort,
and all of these little tools
that you can use very well.
You can find that really
cool stuff quite easily.
MARK MANDEL: The nice
thing is actually,
there's stuff in the
Google Cloud command line
interface that don't
require you to use like said
or [INAUDIBLE].
You can actually tell it
to format stuff in like CSV
or JSON just through the
command line options.
So you can push it to like
all sorts of different things.
It's really impressive.
I've been a long time user
of the code completions
that you can get
through ZSH and bash.
But--
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, actually.
You got me hooked on ZSH.
And that's how I discovered
the code completion.
And the code completion, sorry.
The auto completion.
The impressive thing about
it, about the auto completion,
is that it auto completes
about on many things.
MARK MANDEL: Yes.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Not only the
commands themselves, but also
like instant names.
MARK MANDEL: Like zones.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Zones and bridges.
Which is great, because I never
remember how to write bridges.
I never remember
where the dash goes.
So--
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
Or what was my
compute instance name?
Or like, stuff like that.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: I have one I'm
going to add to the list.
This isn't mine.
This is a coworkers
of ours, Sandeep.
He came up with a nice wave.
And this does use
[INAUDIBLE] But we'll
put it in the show
notes, that literally
lets you pull out
what your project
name is from your kung fu file.
I found that particularly useful
when writing like bash scripts
and make files where
that project detail has
to be sort of in that, as an
argument for certain things.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
That's very nice.
Actually I could
definitely see that as part
of some deployments
scraped or some built part.
Yeah.
That sounds really interesting.
MARK MANDEL: Now we're commonly
building examples and stuff,
where they have to work on
either our project or somebody
else's.
So we can just hard
code a project ID.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
Yeah, I've done that.
I've hard coded many
projects many times.
And then when you want to open
source, you're like, oh, yeah.
Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: Or you're working
on your staging project,
and you're putting
in your project.
And you're like, oh, man, I
have to like-- Yeah, it's bad.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Definitely,
definitely useful.
We'll add that
little command on top
on the show notes in addition
to the link to this article.
OK.
So that was our first
cool thing of the year.
Cool thing of the-- Actually
yeah, cool thing of the year.
MARK MANDEL: That was our
first cool thing of the year.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool
thing of the year.
There you go.
And now we're going to pass
to this amazing interview.
I personally had
lots of fun doing it.
MARK MANDEL: It was
really interesting.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yeah, I think that Ram
is a very interesting guy.
Knows a lot about many things.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
And we're actually
going to be talking about
one of the coolest APIs
that I think we have.
MARK MANDEL: Cloud Vision API.
Very exciting stuff.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So I
say we just go for it.
MARK MANDEL: Sounds good.
We are joined today by
a very special guest.
Very excited to have
you here with us today.
It is Ram Ramanathan.
He is the product manager
for Google Cloud Vision API.
Thank you so much
for joining us, Ram.
RAM RAMANATHAN: Thank you guys.
Thanks for having
me on the show.
MARK MANDEL: An
absolute pleasure.
And I did manage to pronounce
your name correctly?
RAM RAMANATHAN: Yes, you did.
MARK MANDEL: Wonderful.
I like getting that right.
Makes me happy.
So for those people who
aren't familiar with you
and what you do, do
you want to give us
a little bit of your background?
And tell us a little
about yourself?
RAM RAMANATHAN: Sure.
Yeah.
I'm a product manager in
the Google Cloud platform.
I look after some of our
machine learning technologies.
In particular, we just released
our Google Cloud Vision API.
It's one of our key
products that I manage.
And I spend a lot of time
in the technology space
with a variety of different
companies, both in the Bay Area
and in Seattle.
And I'm based in Seattle.
MARK MANDEL: Pretty cool.
So you've got a long history
of sort of doing machine
learning type stuff.
RAM RAMANATHAN: That's right.
I initially started off a lot
in the business intelligence
space, thinking about
how users can make sense
of all the data they collect.
And then moving on to machine
learning in the last few years.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
Can you give us a little
bit of a general idea
of-- So we have machine
learning, and business
intelligence, and so on.
And then on top of that,
there's Cloud Vision API.
What is it?
And how is it related
to machine learning?
RAM RAMANATHAN: Sure.
Google Cloud Vision API really
provides an easy way for you
developers to understand images.
Right?
Basically, the way it
works is we encapsulate
a lot of powerful
machine learning models
that help identify
patterns and images,
and then apply that
to your own images.
So you can-- It's basically
the same technology
that powers things like
Google Photos today.
So in Google Photos,
you are able to search
on your own photos for
things like beaches or things
with dogs.
So photos of your favorite dog.
And the way it does
that is it basically
understands a pattern in
your image for what a dog is,
or what a beach is.
And so it's able to
apply that pattern
across your entire image set.
And so what we've
done in Vision API
is basically encapsulate
similar models like that,
and provide that
as easy-to-use API
so the developer
doesn't need to worry
about all the machine
learning complexity
and the sophistication.
But it really just focus on
hey, you're on my images.
Help me understand what
are the contents of image.
So it's really built on a
powerful machine learning
set of models.
But we provide it to
you as easy-to-use API.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
No, I've definitely become
a big fan of Google Photos
especially.
My favorite search
for some reason,
I like looking at grass.
I just, I find it amazing that
it gets pictures like-- It'll
give me like big, broad sweeps.
And at the same
time, like close-ups
of my dog lying in grass.
Like just like, blades of grass.
And it just picks it out.
And it feels like magic.
It feels like absolute magic.
So that's really cool.
So all right.
So, what does that
kind of translate to?
So if I'm a user of
the Google Vision API,
guess I'm sending it
some kind of image.
And then it's sending me--
What is it sending me back?
What do I get?
RAM RAMANATHAN: Sure.
Basically, what we
do is we've exposed
a set of six powerful features.
The features that we
provide are things
like oneness, label detection.
So basically, if
you give us an image
and you choose
label detection, we
are able to tag an image
across a wide-- or thousands
of different entities
that we recognize.
And we provide that back
to you with a description
of the entity and a confidence
score of how comparable
we think that this entity
actually exists in your image.
Another aspect is,
for example, we're
able to do things like OCR--
Optical Character Recognition.
So if you want to read
the text in your image,
we can apply that
feature on your image.
As part of the
JSON response, you
will get back the
text that we were
able to identify in the image.
We do automatic language
detections of what language
the text belongs to.
And we then provide you a
bounding polybox with xy
coordinates on where we
think the text exists
inside your image.
So similarly we provide
other set of APIs
like facial detection,
which is able to detect
the faces inside the photo,
along with the associated
emotions of that face.
Landmark.
We're able to detect
a wide variety
of different natural
and man-made landmarks.
And logo detection,
which is able to detect
product logos inside an image.
Another aspect is
for folks who do
a lot of crowdsourcing
of images,
basically where their
users upload images.
A constant common
use case is, hey,
can I ensure that I can
moderate better images that
have adult content
or violent content.
So our saved search annotation,
powered by the same technology
that powers our Google Safe
Search in image search,
is able to detect things like
whether an image as adult
content in it, or
whether an image has
violent content in it.
And we give you
back a probability
of whether [INAUDIBLE] it's
likely to very unlikely.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: That
is very cool, actually.
So because that's actually--
Is that the same models that
are powering the Safe Search
option on Google search?
RAM RAMANATHAN: That's right.
So I mean it's a similar
set of models of technology.
But you can imagine like
many of the technology
that powers things are on Google
Safe Search to technologies
that power Google Photos.
And we encapsulate some of
those technologies through API.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
That's really awesome.
I can see a lot
of people working
that need, actually, that API.
And the fact that they can use
it out of the box, just like,
is this adult content or not?
Like, with a simple REST API.
That's really cool.
MARK MANDEL: That's
really, really cool.
No, that's really cool.
And you talked a little sort
of about face detection.
I did happen to see, and we
got a nice demo the other day
from [INAUDIBLE],
one of our teammates,
who helped work on the
cloud vision bot, which
is a cute little bot, that
when it detects your face,
and if you smile at it,
it heads towards you.
And if you frown at it,
it runs away from you.
So I thought it was
really, really cool.
RAM RAMANATHAN: That's right.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Until
you got-- I tried with it.
But for some reason, even
though I was smiling at it,
it was ignoring me.
The problem was
there was no WiFi.
MARK MANDEL: Sure, sure.
You just don't have
a recognizable face.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I must not
have been attractive enough
for bots.
MARK MANDEL: No, that's
totally fair enough.
Talking about face
detection, I can see here
that facial recognition
isn't supported.
Do we want to talk a
little bit about that?
RAM RAMANATHAN: Sure.
I think one of the things
that we are focused on
is user privacy.
And so, what we provide on
the Google Cloud platform
is just ability to detect faces.
We don't do facial recognition.
So as part of a face
detection, we're
able to protect the
faces inside the image.
And we also detect the
associated emotions
of the face, whether a person
is smiling, not smiling.
We don't store the images or the
associated information written
back to the user
on Google service.
We return it back to
you, the end user.
So in that way we're
ensuring that the user has
control of their data and
also associated responses.
MARK MANDEL: That sounds
pretty reasonable.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: That's
very interesting.
So basically we're able to
see if there's any face.
What are they doing?
But we don't know who
they are, basically.
RAM RAMANATHAN: That's correct.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: OK.
RAM RAMANATHAN: Exactly.
MARK MANDEL: That
seems pretty fair.
Sounds pretty fair.
No, that sounds really good.
So, OK.
So I'm actually quite curious.
You've probably got a bit more
visibility than we do on this.
Like, what sort of things
are people doing with this?
Like, what do you
envision people--
I'm sure you've got some ideas.
I mean, this seems like
one of these crazy things
you could do so much with.
RAM RAMANATHAN: Yeah.
There is a wide
variety of use cases.
I think the initial
use case is really
a lot of users
wanting to use label
detection to really manage all
their images, recreate them.
How do you build metadata on
this large catalog of images
that you may have?
That's a common use case that
folks want to use it for.
A lot of media companies want
to build large media catalogs.
Or [INAUDIBLE] companies
[INAUDIBLE] just to manage.
What's the content of my images?
Another use case
is folks who really
want to do things like on
content moderation, right?
In the case of
crowdsource content.
First of all, you still
use label detection
to understand what are the
contents of the images.
But also filter out
or be able to moderate
adult content and violent
content from crowdsource,
so they don't share those
images with their broader user
community.
The other use cases
is really thinking
about how to leverage OCR in
a variety of [INAUDIBLE] form.
Like transactional
applications, people who want to
do things around reading
text from receipts,
or being able to use the
text from these images.
And then do intelligent
things based
on the text that we can
retrieve from the image.
And the fourth use
case, of course,
is just it's more of
an interesting use
case around image
sentiment analysis.
A lot of folks have
been using text
to do sentiment analysis on what
the customer's reception are
of their products.
But with the power of
combination of both image
detection, emotions
from the face,
to product logo
detection, people
can start understanding how
was my product logo associated
with people who are
either smiling or sad?
And what are the other
contents of the image
at a certain point in time?
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, that
sounds pretty great.
RAM RAMANATHAN: Yeah.
Now the sort of
key use cases are
thinking about extracting
taxed, image metadata
management, image sentiment
analysis, and content
moderation.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, I know.
I'm starting to think
about places where
I've seen similar things
happen where people have used
crowdsourcing to do
this sort of stuff,
where you get your audience to
flag whether it's inappropriate
or tag what sort of data
is inside this image.
Whereas now you can look at
doing that automatically, which
I think is pretty powerful.
I'm also just looking forward
to a time where I can just
send a receipt to my expense
provider, and it's like, oh,
I know what that is now.
I'm going to send
that in for you.
Rather than me having
to do all that work.
So that's pretty cool.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
That'd be really awesome.
Yeah.
So we're talking about these
are basically models that
have been trained by Google.
And before we had people maybe
training those models, right?
Is this based on
something that we've
talked before in one of the
cool things of the week?
It's TensorFlow.
And how is it based on--
RAM RAMANATHAN: Yeah.
Could you explain what's the
relationship between TensorFlow
on Google- not Google Photos.
Google Cloud Vision API?
RAM RAMANATHAN: Sure.
One of the things is the way all
these machine learning models
evolved the recent future
to enable and allow
these powerful
scenarios is really
advances in deep learning.
Right?
So deep learning
enables you really
look at unstructured data,
whether it's images, videos,
and really start identifying
patterns in your data set
And within Google,
we have been using
a framework called TensorFlow
to drive a lot of the scenarios.
And we recently open
sourced that in November.
And we had great reception.
A lot of great user adoption.
And so internally
at Google we've
been leveraging frameworks like
that, to build these models.
And what we have done
on the Vision API
is basically just providing
wrappers around that for users
to consume it.
So you can imagine that people
use deep learning frameworks
to build these
sophisticated models,
and then basically once
the models are ready to go,
we're exposing
that as REST APIs.
MARK MANDEL: That's very cool.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Also, could
you give us a little bit more
about what other products
use TensorFlow at Google?
RAM RAMANATHAN: Yep.
Inside Google, we're using
TensorFlow from everything
from speech recognition in
the Google app, in OK Google,
to how we do things around
smart reply and inboxes--
that's a new feature.
We just introduced an inbox
that allows you to intelligently
pick common responses to your
emails coming into your inbox--
to how we do image
searches in Google Photos.
One of the interesting
things about TensorFlow
is its ability to adapt to
a broad set of scenarios.
And also the fact
that its ability
to run not just on
a single smartphone,
but across thousands of
computers and data centers.
So its ability to
scale, where you can now
imagine some of these models
running on your Android device
or Google box.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Something
really interesting
that you mentioned
is that TensorFlow
is powering speech recognition.
And I know that
speech recognition
is a very hard thing to do.
Like I'm always impressed
that my phone understands me.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: With my accent.
That's very good job.
MARK MANDEL: It's impressive
that it understands you,
and it understands me.
And it understands
everyone else as well,
like with all our accents.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: That's
really interesting.
But the interesting thing
is it doesn't necessarily
run through an API.
Right?
Like, it actually
runs on your phone.
RAM RAMANATHAN: That's right.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So could
you tell us a little bit
about how do we even do that?
Like the fact that there's so
much information about a model,
but still fits on your phone.
RAM RAMANATHAN: Yeah, I think
that's really one of the things
that we're enabling through
the TensorFlow framework
enables its ability to support
of a wide variety of devices.
So basically, you
can imagine people
are using really sophisticated
hardware to train
these large speech
models, and then you
can imagine the
power of TensorFlow
is we can take that model
and actually just enable it
to run on your mobile device.
Over time, this
allows users to think
about more intelligent
scenarios where
they can drive faster
response, in more real time,
integrate machine learning
real time into user workforce.
And that's really
where we can start
driving more intelligent
user workflows where it just
becomes pervasive.
A great example is what
we're doing that in Google
Now, where we just give you
these flash cards as part
of your user workflow.
But that's just a tip
of the ice of what
we can do with TensorFlow.
Is make more apps
that's intelligent.
That's really our focus.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: OK.
So my next question,
then, is since the robot
didn't recognize my smile
because the WiFi was down,
could it be possible to
have Google Cloud Vision
API as not an API, but something
that you can install it?
Or is the model way too big?
RAM RAMANATHAN: Yeah, actually.
We do have subsets
of what API supports
on the cloud on Android devices.
We released, recently
released, what
we call the mobile vision SDK.
That's part of the Android
SDK, where we provide things
around, similar things like
around, face detection.
We provide some of the aspects
around some of the emotion
models have a priority
on detecting smiles.
And we're also providing things
around additional aspects,
like that's very mobile.
So now you focus like things
like barcode recognition.
MARK MANDEL: That's
really, really cool.
Just looking at that
now I didn't even
realize that exists.
That's really cool.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: That's
the good thing about--
RAM RAMANATHAN: Yeah, it's
on developers.google.com back
vision.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yeah, we'll add links
to that in the show notes.
Yeah, I was saying,
that's the good thing
about these podcasts.
Is every single episode,
I learn new stuff.
MARK MANDEL: I learn
new stuff, exactly.
That's really fun.
All right, wonderful.
So I guess, is there anything
about Vision API or TensorFlow
or machine learning
that you want
to talk about, that we haven't
really sort of covered yet?
RAM RAMANATHAN: No, you
guys hit on a lot of things.
I think really
where ever you are,
we're at the infancy
of how people
are bringing machine learning
into their applications.
One of things is
machine learning
is really being used in
a lot of ed scenarios,
or requires large amounts
of compute and PhDs
to make it functional.
And really what
we're looking to do
is how do we take this
knowledge and make
it pervasive, so people really
start incorporating machine
learning into their
everyday applications
and make all user
workflows more intelligent?
MARK MANDEL: Sort of bring it
down to the consumer level,
so it becomes easy to use.
Yeah, I know I've looked
at machine learning just
in passing every so often.
And every time I do, I'm
like, oh, this is scary.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
There's a very good course on
MARK MANDEL: Coursera.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Coursera.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
I've done that.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I
tried to go through it.
It gets really
intense, really fast.
MARK MANDEL: It's
really good, though.
RAM RAMANATHAN: Yeah, there's a
lot of good content out there.
I think more and more the
more applications will
just-- I think people will
start expecting like-- People
have gotten used to Google Now.
Gets its intelligence
flashcards.
And people are getting used to
how they can search in photos.
And I think they're
going to start
expecting that in all their
other applications over time.
And I think the more we can
start providing these APIs,
I think it will make it easier
for developers incorporate
that.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
just make it sort of,
I can plug in, take advantage
and just use and be on my way.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: That's the
great thing about Cloud Vision
API, is that yes, machine
learning is complicated.
And yes, you may need to
understand a lot of stuff
to train a model correctly.
But hey, if you know how to
do Curl and use a REST API,
you're good.
MARK MANDEL: You're good to go,
and you're going to have it.
So that's really awesome.
Brilliant.
All right, well, thank you
so much, Ram, for joining us.
We really, really appreciate it.
This was a really fun interview.
RAM RAMANATHAN: Thank you.
Thanks for having me.
Thanks for having me, guys.
MARK MANDEL: All right.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Thank you.
MARK MANDEL: Thank you.
Thank you very much
for joining us, Ram.
That was a really
interesting interview.
I know I learned a
whole lot during that.
It was great.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
that was awesome.
I got really excited
about many other projects
that I think we could
build on top of that API.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
Yeah.
As is always with this podcast,
I'll end up listening somewhere
and I'm like, man, I gotta
go play with that thing.
It sounds great.
But yeah, enough
time in the day.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So.
OK.
So before we end
this amazing episode,
let's go with the
question of the week.
MARK MANDEL: Yes, you
brought up an interesting one
which I hadn't really
encountered before.
Which was, if you have a file
within Google Cloud Storage,
but you want to provide
temporary access to it.
So it's not just
public to internet.
You're like, I want it to be
available for like an hour
or something like that.
How do you go about doing that?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
So there's actually
one way of doing it,
which is the normal way.
And I've seen people
trying to do it.
It's kind of not
very useful to do,
which is you actually add
one e-mail to the ACL,
to the Access Control List.
And then after a
while, you remove it.
MARK MANDEL: OK.
Feels manual.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
That kind of works.
I mean, you can deal
with the script.
There's a recipe for that.
So that kind of works.
And you have the
limit of there's only
that person that will
be able to access
that file during that period
of time that you want.
MARK MANDEL: So that's like when
you want like a specific user
to be have it?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
Problem with that, the user
needs to log in to do it.
MARK MANDEL: OK.
I got it.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So depending
what you're trying to do,
depending the kind of
app you're developing,
might be a little bit hard.
So not always the
perfect solution.
Then we have a second
solution, which is the one
that I want to talk
about today, which is
what we call the signed URLs.
So the signed URLs
is just a URL that
is a way of accessing
that resource that is only
valid for some period of time.
MARK MANDEL: OK.
So it's totally public,
but you can only
access it for like an
hour, or a day, or a week.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So you're
going to be able to say, OK,
I'm going to provide
access to that resource.
But I'm not going
to make it public.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Instead, the only way
to access that resource is going
to be going through that URL.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And
after whatever time
you choose-- one hour,
one minute, whatever you
want-- it will just disappear.
MARK MANDEL: OK.
So that could be really good
for access tokens, or something
like that, something.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
I've personally used it
for Google Cloud spin,
so that called them up.
We had one thing
that we wanted to do,
is when someone jumps and
we have this image that is--
MARK MANDEL: Oh, I see.
Yeah
FRANCESC CAMPOY: We
need to visualize it.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And we don't
want those images to be public.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And
we visualize the image
for like five seconds.
So what we did was to provide
a signed URL that could
be valid for like 30 seconds,
MARK MANDEL: OK.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Then the
visualizer is able to show it.
And if anyone was
able to find how--
MARK MANDEL: Somehow get it.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Find the
URL, if it's after 30 seconds,
sorry, it's too late.
MARK MANDEL: That's
really interesting.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: OK.
That's a really interesting one.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Very useful.
MARK MANDEL: Didn't
know that existed.
That's really, really cool.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
And creating them, we'll
add a link to the notes.
But it's actually really simple.
You can do it
directly with GSUtil.
So the Google Cloud
Storage Util command.
Or you can also do
it through REST APIs.
Personally, we did it
directly on App Engine.
So from App Engine you can call
a couple APIs and that's it.
MARK MANDEL: It just works.
That's lovely.
OK.
That's really handy to know.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
So this is the end
of the first episode.
But before we
actually say goodbye--
MARK MANDEL: Yeah?
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Where can I find you?
MARK MANDEL: OK.
So I'm doing a few
interesting things.
I will be at the launch
hackathon in San Francisco.
After that I'll be at GDC, the
Game Developers Conference.
Also in San Francisco.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
MARK MANDEL: And then
looks like I will also
be in [INAUDIBLE] in San Jose.
So I'm not really leaving
California very much.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
You're not even leaving
North California.
So really not far away.
MARK MANDEL: I am
going back to Australia
for a bit of a holiday.
But that's not work-related.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
It's slightly more far away.
Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
How about yourself?
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Well, so in a couple
weeks I'm going to [INAUDIBLE].
So it's a really cool conference
that takes place in Brussels.
I'm going to be in managing
the Go [INAUDIBLE].
There's going to
be a [INAUDIBLE].
I'm going to be talking there.
MARK MANDEL: Fun.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yep,
going to be lots of fun.
The week after that I'm going to
Paris for the Google dev fest.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: We're going
to have a bunch of developers.
And if you're going to
be around, come say hi.
We're going to try to also
organize a couple hackathons
or workshops Let's see.
I'm still not sure.
Are we still planning that?
MARK MANDEL: Still planning it.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
But it's going to be
the first week of March.
MARK MANDEL: We're
in the same phase
with like GDC and [INAUDIBLE].
Stuff's going to happen there.
It'll be good.
It'll be good stuff.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And
then, I'm actually
really excited about this one.
I'm going to Dubai.
I'm going to Dubai for
Golfer Con, United Emirates.
No, wait.
United Arab Emirates.
UAE.
That's it.
So Yeah.
Very excited about that one too.
MARK MANDEL: All
right, wonderful.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Otherwise,
if you want to contact us,
and you turn out to be here
in California or somewhere
where I'm going
to be traveling--
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
There's a couple ways
they can contact us.
MARK MANDEL: They can get us by
e-mail at hello@jcppodcast.com.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: The web page.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
JCP Podcast.com
FRANCESC CAMPOY: The Twitter.
MARK MANDEL: JCP podcast.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: The subreddit.
MARK MANDEL: Slash
our JCP podcast.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Good job.
And on Google+.
MARK MANDEL: +Podcast.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And
I think that's it.
MARK MANDEL: I think that's it.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: If you can't
reach us through one of those,
then I don't know.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
just let us know.
But how do they let us know?
[LAUGHTER]
Anyway, thank you so much
for being here again today.
That was an awesome episode.
Very excited about
the rest of the year.
MARK MANDEL: A
pleasure, as always.
And I'll see you all next week.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
See you next week.
Bye.
[MUSIC PLAYING]